die New York Times zitiert jetzt
uS-Analysten von denen es heißt die
Ukraine verteile ihre Truppen nicht
richtig deckt sich das mit ihren
Analysen
und es Situation ist natürlich nicht
einfach für die Ukraine und es ist
natürlich so dass die ukrainischen
Soldaten an der Front stehen und dort
quasi den Kampf gegen die Russen führen
zu Befreiung ihres Landes und es wurde
schon sehr komisch an wenn dann aus der
Distanz man sie wissen lässt was sie zu
tun hätten oder auch nicht ich habe auch
schon oft versucht es ein bisschen
darzustellen mit der Schwierigkeit des
Geländes das Gelände ist sehr sehr flach
sie müssen sich das vorstellen wie ein
Schachbrett und die einzelnen Felder
sind geteilt von den anderen durch man
sie windschutzgürtel durch er baumlinien
und das Problem ist wenn man direkt von
einem Feld auf das nächste Ziel kommt
man in einen Abwehrkampf zwischen
panzerwerfen kann Hubschraubern und
anderen Möglichkeiten gemischt und das
Problem ist man versuchte Seite sich an
diesen Randlinien also an den zwischen
ihnen der Fehler sondern das ist sehr
sehr langsam aber es hat zumindest
substanziell soweit erfolgt das ist
ihnen gelingt langsam vor zu marschieren
jetzt da wenn man betrachtet was in den
letzten Wochen in der letzten zwei
Wochen vor allem in den amerikanischen
Medien geschrieben worden ist so drängt
sich einen der Eindruck auf dass man
bereits auf der Suche nach einem
Schuldigen ist für das Scheitern dieser
Offensive ich denke darum hat er auch
gerade solutioni also generalstoffchef
solutioni versuchte den Angriff nach
vorne zu wagen vor allem auch um die
Moral der eigenen Truppen zu stärken
darum ist auch die Ankündigung der F16
so wichtig denn der Lieferung der 16 so
wichtig weil der Soldat dann der Front
der quasi hier sich durch die
Minenfelder Vorarbeiten muss der hat das
Gefühl jawohl es passiert etwas wenn ich
noch ein bisschen durchhalte dann hat es
möglicherweise eine Entscheidung
Unterschied aber tatsächlich am besten
beurteilen die Lage das kann nur der
ukrainische Soldat und europäische
generalstoffe vor Ort der diese Truppen
führt bzw der dort diesen Kampf zu
tragen hat
trotzdem sind sie beobachten der die
Situation auch aus der Ferne wie sie
sagen es gibt Berichte die die jetzt
nahe liegen dass die Ukraine tatsächlich
ihre Taktik in Teilen auch geändert hat
ist es das was sie meinen mit sie
marschieren nach vorne ist es das was
ich mit ihren Analysen auch deckt
ja das bei einem derart komplexen
Unternehmen wie also das Durchbrechen
von gegnerischen Stellungen ist es so
dass eine ganze Reihe von Fähigkeiten
vorhanden sein müssen und diese
Fähigkeiten aufeinander abgestimmt zum
Einsatz gebracht werden was jetzt etwas
verklausuliert klingt bedeutet das
einfach einzelne Waffengattungen gewisse
Rollen haben diese quasi dann im
entscheidenden Moment das danke fürs
durchführen müssen und diese Rollen wenn
Sie alle ineinander quasi gefügt sind
führen dazu dass es dann so einen
Durchbruch kommt am besten natürlich
nach wenigen Tagen der dann also dazu
führt dass die ganze gegnerische Form
zusammenbricht das war aber bis jetzt
nicht der Fall warum weil einerseits
aufgrund des Umstandes dass manche
Fähigkeit nicht vorhanden waren diese
z.B das niederhalten des Gegners nicht
möglich war und weil auch auf der
russischen Seite durch dieses
monatelange Eingaben ein
verteidigungsdispositiv vorhanden war
das in dieser Qualität seinesgleichen
sucht das gab es eigentlich das letzte
Mal im Zweiten Weltkrieg vergleichbar
mit zum Beispiel der Schlacht um Kurs
oder zum Beispiel bei der Wiener
Operationen Plattensee wurden derartige
Verteidigungsanlage eingerichtet dass
die Länder Ukraine ist das ist eben
nicht alle Möglichkeiten gemeinsam dass
sie nicht alle Fähigkeiten gemeinsam
einsetzen kann sondern aufgrund der
Waffenlieferung aus dem Westen immer
Stück für Stück einsetzt und das ist das
Problem denn die Russen können sich
immer wieder auf diese Fähigkeiten neu
einstellen und können Sie dann in Teilen
schlagen und das ist das Dilemma das die
Ukraine hier quasi ganz klar hat als
solches
gerne einmal über die von Ihnen
angesprochenen Waffenlieferung sprechen
auch weil diese Frage von unseren
zuschauernden Zuschauern kommt also
Dänemark und die Niederlande haben
angekündigt der Ukraine ab zum
Jahreswechsel die ersten F16 Kampfjets
liefern zu wollen was würde das
tatsächlich verändern hier schreibt auch
jemand bei Youtube halten Sie die
Lieferung von F 16 Kampfjets für einen
gamechanger für die Ukraine
nun kein einzelnes Waffensystem ist kein
gamechanger die Zusammenschau der
Waffensysteme und die Zusammenwirken der
Waffensysteme das macht den Unterschied
und das ist das Dilemma das Problem ist
wir sind auch Opfer unserer eigenen
Propaganda ich sag das jetzt da so wie
es ist ganz hart warum weil wir uns
natürlich am Beginn des Krieges
eingeredet haben der ukrainische Soldat
hat mit der deutschen Panzerfaust in der
Hand die Russen aufgehalten das stimmt
so nicht das waren die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte und zwar die Streitkräfte
die am Land gekämpft haben in der Luft
zu sehen und auch im cyberraum unter
anderem Stellen wo die ist gar nicht
mitbekommen die waren verantwortlich für
diesen Erfolg sie wurden einmal immer
wieder abgenutzt und das Liefern vom
Waffensystemen hat ihnen die Möglichkeit
gegeben dann wieder in die Offensive zu
gehen so war es auch bei dieser
Offensive wenn Sie sich erinnern
gesagt ich brauche noch einmal 300
Kampfpanzer sechs bis 700 Kampf
Schützenpanzer 5
Systeme zu gehen niemand hat eigentlich
gesagt dass nur ein Teil davon
eingetroffen ist also man nimmt dann
zwischen 50
60 Prozent im Wesentlichen denken Sie
nur alleine an die Leopards
zweikampfpanzer und das was dann zur
Verfügung stand das hatte dann verwendet
um in die Offensive zu gehen aber es
haben wesentliche Elemente gefehlt wie
zum Beispiel funktionierende
Luftstreitkräfte und es ist nun mal Teil
auch der Kriegsführung und folgt der
Logik der kriegsung dass man wenn man
einen erfolgreichen landoperation
durchführen möchte auch funktionierende
Luftstreitkräfte hat die der Luftraum
über den vorstoßenden Kräften schützen
bzw verhindern dass zum Beispiel so wie
geschehen die russischen Kampfflugzeuge
angreifen die russischen kampfhubwagen
Hubschrauber und Flugzeuge angreifen
können außerhalb der Reichweite quasi
der ukrainischen Flieger wir als
Beispiel und das ist das Problem wir
liefern also quasi an die Ukraine also
der Westen liefern die Ukraine und es
konnte immer ein Stück weit herein und
zu spielen und damit ist die Ukraine
gezwungen das Beste daraus zu machen und
das tut sie auch und versuchte hier
langsam vorzumücken aber die Verluste
sind natürlich schwierig und dieses
langsame vorigen macht es den Russen
immer wieder möglich dahinter also
hinter dem bereits besetzten Stellungen
neue Stellungen zu richten würde das
alles schnell rasch auf einmal gehen
also dieser operative Durchbruch im
Sinne eines Dammbruch ist dann wäre das
natürlich nicht möglich das ist aber
nicht der Fall weil die Ukraine was sie
hier Fähigkeiten hat die sie dir nach
wie vor fehlen und das Lieferung F 16
wenn bei einer möglichen neuen Offensive
wieder alles zusammengespart wird und
dann gemeinsam eingesetzt werden
okay ich wollte sie nämlich gerade
fragen sie sagen ein Waffensystem
alleine ist nicht der Game changer aber
gesetz den Fall diese Kampf des werden
tatsächlich zum Jahreswechsel geliefert
was können die dann in dieser
Gegenoffensive bewirken
also gesetzt auf alles kommt zu einer
neuen Offensive zum Beispiel im Frühjahr
oder im Sommer nächsten Jahres dann wäre
es so dass zum Beispiel auch eine
gewisse Anzahl von Kampfflugzeugen und
hier ist wichtig zu verstehen das
Kampfflugzeug ist die Plattform es geht
also auch hier um den entsprechenden
Luft Luft und luftbodenwaffen dass diese
so aktiv wirksam können dass sie im
Falle zum Beispiel dieser möglichen
Offensive den Luftraum über den
geplanten Raum des Durchbruches sichern
und dafür sorgen dass z.B die
gegnerischen Kampfflugzeuge gegen
Kampfhubschrauber auf Distanz gehalten
werden und nicht angreifen können die
vormarschieren Kolonnen sie können aber
auch dafür sorgen dass sie mit
entsprechenden weitreichenden
luftbodenwaffen Kommando Strukturen des
Gegners sind in diesem Fall der Russen
angreifen Logistik Punkte angreifen oder
und das ist auch ganz besonders wichtig
dafür sorgen dass die Reserven die die
Russen heranführen wenn zum Beispiel
einen Einbruch passiert ist nicht diese
Einbruchstelle reichen sondern quasi
vorher schon zu einem Einsatz der
Luftwaffe kommt in diesem 16 und diese
Abwehr folgt das ist der Punkt 16
einbringen können unabhängig davon dass
natürlich durch die Verfügung von
Waffensystemen Österreich sind auch
während des Konflikts in der
Vorbereitung also in der sogenannten
shaping-phase die wir auch jetzt ja
gesehen haben auch Maßnahmen getroffen
werden können dass der Gegner bereits so
geschwächt ist dass er beim Angriff
möglicherweise leichter durchstoßen wird
das heißt es macht sehr wohl einen
Unterschied
sie haben jetzt gerade auch die Luft
bodenwaffensysteme angesprochen eins ist
ja Taurus Marschflugkörper über deren
Lieferung in Deutschland immer noch
diskutiert wird welchen impact hätte
dieser Waffentyp denn für die Ukraine
ja ich möchte vielleicht ganz kurz
voranstellen ich möchte als Österreicher
mich nicht Anlassen also hier quasi
auszurichten was ist er hier ein
Waffensystem an aus Deutschland zu
liefern wäre und wie ihr so diese
eingesetzt wird ich kann Ihnen nur als
neutraler Beobachter mit einer
entsprechenden militärischen Ausbildung
sagen was man also herleiten kann also
wie ein Arzt den sie zu ziehen um einen
zweiten Befund zu haben unter daraus hat
natürlich schon einige Fähigkeiten die
zum Beispiel Skype und Storm das sind
jenes System mit dieser vorgeliefert
worden sind nicht haben zum Beispiel ist
es so dass die von mir genannten Systeme
sich ja besonders dazu eignen
bunkerbrechen wirksam zu werden also
tief unter die Erde einzudringen und
dort Bunker zu zerstören dazu haben sie
einen speziellen Zünder verfügbar und
der Taurus kann zum Beispiel hier
variiert werden das heißt er ist zum
Beispiel besser geeignet zum Angreifen
werden aber sie haben nur ein
kreisrundesloch in der Brücken Decke
aber keine Zerstörung das kann der Chaos
mit seine Fähigkeiten besser er hat eine
höhere Reichweite sein Flugverhalten ist
wesentlich günstiger damit ist der
schwerer Angreifer durch die russische
Flieger werden
paar Monaten laufen verbessert hat und
natürlich auch die Quantität der
verfügbaren Systeme macht ihr einen
Unterschied das heißt man kann also
nicht nur immer zwei drei Sturm Shadow
oder skalpaketen einsetzen mit dem
wenigen Plattformen die man hat sondern
man könnte quasi massierter vorgehen und
das Massieren da Kräfte bringt immer
noch den Vorteil dass der Gegner so
getroffen wird dass es sich
möglicherweise nicht erholen kann denn
von diesen kleinen Schlägen die zwei
spektakulär sind kann er sich immer
wieder neu aufstellen und neu erholen
und das macht natürlich hier den Taurus
interessant für die Ukraine
ich glaube aus ihrer Analyse ist klar
geworden so wie es jetzt gerade läuft
wird es sich vermutlich noch lange
hinziehen und erhoffte Erfolge bleiben
dann möglicherweise aus wie kann diese
gegen Offensive der Ukraine ich weiß es
ist die eine Million Euro Frage aber wie
könnte diese Gegenoffensive
möglicherweise noch erfolgreich werden
nun die Kriegsgeschichte ist voller
Beispiele wo ein Unterlage liegender
Gegner plötzlich dann einen Durchbruch
erzielte man ihm so nicht zugetraut
hätte und da Historiker hat dann die
Unart ihnen zu erklären warum das
genauso gekommen ist und warum es
logisch war es kann natürlich
theoretisch sein dass auch hier ein
eigenes eintritt dass wir so nicht
voraussehen können es kann sein dass
eine Eigendynamik entsteht aufgrund zum
Beispiel einem Durchbruch eine einzelne
ukrainische Einheit bricht plötzlich
durch es kommt zu einer Panikreaktion
die russischen Stellungen lösen sich auf
und man flüchtet so etwas gab es bereits
bei hakiv war genau das der Fall und die
Russen sind zurückgeflüchtet und wurden
dann bei aus Kiel das ist ein Fluss
quasi aber westlich von kubianski mit
höchster notwasser wieder aufgehalten
das könnte sich durchaus wiederholen das
ist ja hier auch das sind Zentralraum
passiert und die russischen Truppen
zurückgeben bist doch noch oder
vielleicht sogar bis Melitta obwohl es
kann aber auch sein das ist nicht
passiert und dass die Ukraine sich quasi
auch jetzt in der letzten Tagen mit
ihren Reserven übernimmt und diese
Reserven dann eigentlich genau diese
Kräfte sind die man brauchen würde um
sich zu konsolidieren um in den Winter
zu gehen und dann die nächste Offensive
vorzubereiten ja das kann man jetzt aus
der Ferne nicht sagen was man aufgrund
der Analyse der vorliegenden Videos und
auch aus den Analyse der sozialen
Netzwerke sagen kann ist dass es heftig
und intensive Kämpfe gibt dass die
Ukraine alles einsetzt was sie zur
Verfügung hat alles was er so quasi hier
auch vom Westen quasi an
ausbildungsunterstützung passiert ist
kommt also hier in diesem Fall jetzt an
wir haben also Waffensysteme die
eingesetzt sind die geliefert worden
sind und so weiter und so fort wir haben
auch die Russen die versuchen hier alles
dagegen zu setzen sie dürfen nicht
vergessen auch die russische Moral hat
sich zum Teil erwiesentlich verändert
die Stimmung in den russischen sozialen
Netzwerken ist ganz anders als das noch
bei Haki war oder auch bei Person
sondern nach den ersten brennenden
Leopard ich sage es Ihnen wie es ist hat
man also quasi schon gehört oder auch
nach dem brennenden breit ist also wir
haben auch das geschafft die werden das
jetzt weiter durchhalten wir haben jetzt
also ganz kleinen Kampf der Willen beide
Parteien sind ineinander verzahnt und
jetzt wo das Hin und Her das ist die
Frage wer wird sich durchsetzen und wie
wird dann weitergehen
ich würde ihnen abschließend gerne noch
eine Frage von unserem Zuschauer Karli
Lukas Weitergeben der fragt wenn die
Regenzeit zurückkommt kann die Taktik
der Ukraine Lieferketten kommandosten
und Gerät anzugreifen weitergeführt
werden auch wenn alles im Schlamm
versinkt mit Blick auf den Herbst und
den Winter
ja das geht natürlich tatsächlich also
moderne Waffensysteme sind in der Lage
bei allen Witterungsbedingungen
eingesetzt zu werden auch bei extremen
Witterungsbedingungen und zum Beispiel
wenn es so der Flughafen ausgeliefert
wird dann kann er genau diese Lücke
schließen bis zur nächsten Offensive und
kann zu diesen abnutzungserfolg
tatsächlich ja mit sich bringen das ist
natürlich klar und auch möglich es ist
vielleicht auch wichtig zu verstehen
dass die Einschränkungen die sich
ergeben beim Einsatz zum Beispiel der
Storm steht das Kalb wird auch das Taos
nicht so sehr die Waffensysteme an sich
sind sondern vor allem die Plattformen
das Problem ist die Ukraine hatten eine
gewisse Anzahl von Plattformen um dieses
System einzusetzen darum sehen wir immer
nur alle zwei Tage zwei drei Tage
spektakuläre Einsätze aber eben zu wenig
massiert um dem Gegner in diesem Fall
die Russen wirklich schmerzhaft zu
schaden so dass er quasi gezwungen ist
der Handlungen zu setzen und hier ist es
so dass gerade auch die die einsetzende
oder der beginnende Winter
natürlich genutzt werden kann von
Ukraine dieses Momentum weiter aufrecht
zu halten
sagt Oberst Markus Reißner vielen Dank
für Ihre Zeit und für die Einschätzung
danke nach Wien